he also is removing Adam Schiff and
ilhan Omar and Eric swallow from some of
their committees they should not be on
committees these are not good people or
good Americans and he really crushed a
reporter who went after him for doing
just that
Intel committee is Santos on the Intel
committee
am I allowing ship am I allowing shift
to be on other committees
go right ahead
um
for your whole house with taking off
other Democrats
but he said that lying to us is
something that means you should be
sure maybe
well let me be very
he's got elected by
his district so
okay let me be very clear and respectful
to you you asked me a question when I
answer it it's the answer to your
question you don't get to determine
whether I answer your question or not
okay in all respect thank you you don't
know let's answer her question
you just raised a question I'm going to
be very clear with you the Intel
committee is different you know why
because what happens in the Intel
committee you don't know what happens in
the Intel committee although the secrets
are going on in the world
other members of Congress don't know
what did Adam Schiff do as the chairman
of the Intel committee what Adam Schiff
did use his power as a chairman and lie
to the American public even the expector
general said it when Devin Nunes put out
a memo he said it was false when we had
a laptop he used it before an election
to be politics and say that it was false
instead it was the Russians when he knew
different when he knew the intel if you
talk to John Radcliffe dni he came out
ahead of time and says there's no Intel
to prove that and he used his position
as chairman knowing he has information
the rest of America does not and lied to
the American public when a whistleblower
came forward he said he did not know the
individual even though his staff had met
with him and set it up so no he does not
have a right to sit on that but I will
not be like Democrats and play politics
with Thief where they removed
Republicans from committees and all
committees so yes he can serve on a
committee but he will not serve on Intel
because it goes to the National Security
of America and I will always put them
first all right but you know what those
voters elected shift even though he lied
those voters elected swallow even though
he lied to the American public too so
you know what I'll respect his voters
too and they'll serve on committees but
they will not serve on a place that has
National Security relevance because
Integrity matters to me that's the
answer to your question so this is what
we've been waiting for from Republicans
for quite some time stand up for the
right things play ball play ball hard
use some of the tools that they're
always using against you guys and note
the the clarity that he's speaking with
you know he's not Shifty it's just here
I we know that he was lying Schiff we'll
get to that in just a second we know he
was lying and these are State secrets on
the Intel committee that someone like
ilhan Omar should not have that someone
like swalwell should not have that
someone like shift should not have
foreign
[Music]